oui alors c'est choquant au sens où
emmanuel macron a prétendu qu'il allait
révolutionner la politique désormais il
y aurait un mouvement est pas un parti
excellent est complètement différent de
ce qu'on avait connu jusqu'à présent
si vous y avez cru évidemment c'est
choquant mais comme c'est pas exactement
mon cas je crois que les partis
politiques on a ça en euros une
légitimité un rôle qui est de gagner des
élections de permettre au pouvoir
d'exercer son quand ils sont dans la
majorité pouvoir peindre gouvernement
pendant d'exercer son pouvoir
je ne suis pas surpris que la démarche
ne soit pas nécessairement démocratique
franchement avec